(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, a gente vai estudar, então, o
que acontece com o imóvel quando ele não
é arrematado em 1º e 2º leilão.
Falei na aula anterior que, depois do 2º
leilão, o credor fiduciário, que na maioria dos
casos são bancos ou grandes construtoras, eles estão
livres para fazer o que eles quiserem com
o bem.
Agora, tem em mente que a maioria dos
credores fiduciários são bancos, e não é interessante
para o banco terem em sua carteira imóvel.
Então, o banco vai tentar se livrar daquele
bem, porque o banco quer dinheiro, ele não
quer ficar com o imóvel em seu estoque.
Então, muitas vezes, existem excelentes oportunidades para você
comprar o imóvel bem abaixo do preço dele
de mercado, pós leilão.
Então, vamos lá.
O que acontece quando o imóvel não é
arrematado?
Os bancos podem escolher o que eles vão
fazer.
Os bancos escolhem, normalmente, fazer um 3º leilão,
realizar a venda direta daquele bem, licitação aberta
ou licitação fechada.
No 3º leilão, é o que os bancos
mais costumam utilizar.
Nessa modalidade, não vai existir nenhum tipo de
rescrição imposta pela lei, pelo valor que o
banco vai cobrar, e também não há necessidade
de realizar aquela notificação do devedor.
Por quê?
Porque a lei exige que o devedor seja
notificado do 1º e do 2º leilão, justamente
para que ele possa exercer o seu direito
de preferência sobre aquele bem.
Esse direito de preferência não existe depois da
realização do 1º e do 2º leilão.
Como eu já falei antes, depois do 2º
leilão, caso não seja arrematado aquele bem, o
bem é definitivamente do credor.
O credor terá a propriedade plena daquele bem
e pode fazer o que ele quiser com
aquele bem.
Então, não existe requisito de valor, não existe
requisito para que o devedor seja notificado da
realização desse 3º leilão.
Não existe direito de preferência do devedor nesse
3º leilão.
Como é que vai acontecer esse 3º leilão?
O credor vai escolher um leiloeiro de sua
preferência e esse leiloeiro vai realizar esse 3º
leilão.
Como a gente já falou, sem requisito de
preço, o credor vai estipular o preço que
ele quiser para aquele imóvel e sem necessidade
de notificação do devedor sobre a data daquele
leilão.
Uma outra modalidade muito utilizada pelos credores é
a venda direta.
Na venda direta, vai levar o bem aquele
que primeiro deram a oferta para aquele bem.
Então, vai ficar estipulado um preço mínimo para
aquele bem, o credor vai estipular esse preço
mínimo, o primeiro que ofertar o preço mínimo
vai levar aquele bem.
Aí que não faz sentido você pagar mais
do que o preço mínimo, porque não existe
disputa.
Então, não tem porque você cobrar mais do
que o valor mínimo estipulado por aquele credor.
A maioria dos credores colocam o imóvel em
venda direta diretamente com os leiloeiros que realizaram
o 1º e o 2º leilão.
Então, no site dos leiloeiros vai ser possível
você encontrar essas oportunidades pós-leilão.
Você vai filtrar a oportunidade pós-leilão, o
leiloeiro vai te informar que aquele leilão ocorreu
em determinada data, que aquele imóvel não foi
arrematado em 1º e 2º leilão e que
ele está em oportunidade de venda pós-leilão
pelo valor mínimo estipulado pelo credor daquele imóvel.
Então, basta que você ofereça o valor mínimo
que aquele imóvel vai ser seu, sem maior
dificuldade.
E existe ainda um caso peculiar, que é
o caso da caixa econômica.
Por que é importante a gente sempre falar
da caixa econômica?
A caixa é o banco que oferece mais
dinheiro para que as pessoas financiem a compra
de um imóvel.
Então, a caixa é responsável por quase 70
% dos leilões ex-prejudiciais que existem.
Já que ela é o banco que mais
empresta, ela é o banco com maior nível
de inadimplência.
E por ter maior nível de inadimplência, necessariamente
vai ter que realizar leilão para alienar aquele
imóvel e livrar o devedor daquela dívida.
A caixa adota 4 modalidades de venda pós
-leilão.
A primeira é a venda online, depois a
venda direta online, a licitação fechada e a
licitação aberta.
Vamos estudar cada uma delas.
A venda online.
A caixa coloca o imóvel para a venda
online, define dia e hora para encerrar a
venda online.
Será uma espécie de terceiro leilão de forma
online.